From there, let's take a look at the object life cycle.
Creating a new object in Unreal
is as easy as calling the new object line
with the appropriate parameters.
When we actually create the object,
the following operations are going on under the hood.
We malloc the raw data, finding out how big it is
and allocating the associated memory footprint for it.
We then call memset zero
and clear all the associated memory
because we're about to populate it.
We then call the classes constructor
that initializes the virtual table
and initializes all properties within that block of memory.
From there, we copy over the archetype with a mem copy
and Unreal works from a template system
called the class default object.
We then have the post construction initialization,
which is where we duplicate all values from the CDO
into this new block of data.
From there, we load all properties
from configuration files.
We load all properties that would require from .config
or .ini files through a get defaults call.
Lastly, we call post init properties,
which is a gameplay function that we can implement
and use to drive gameplay logic.
Actors have a very specific life cycle
that we can absolutely use to our advantage.
Actors have a huge number of virtual functions
that we can override to add gameplay functionality.
Let's take a look how we can spawn an actor
and break down its subsequent life cycle.
As an actor is in the world,
we need to route our spawn
through the world we wish to spawn it into
and give it a transform to spawn at.
So in this example, we've got a transform defined.
In this case, we'll just use its default values.
We then grab a reference to the world
we want to spawn the actor in
and call its template its spawn actor function.
We give it a template, in this case, just actor,
and pass it in a class that we'd like to spawn
and a transform that we'd want it to spawn at.
As mentioned on the opening slide,
actors have got a number of critical functions
that are important for us to understand
when building systems.
Initialize components pre and post
is called when spinning up the actor.
This function is passed through to any components
that are on the set actor for their own initializations.
Begin play is called
as soon as the actor is spawned and is usable.
It's essentially finished its initialization at this point.
Tick is called at regular intervals
with every frame being its default,
with delta time being passed in as a parameter.
The length of a frame may vary wildly
on a per client basis.
So using delta time in our calculations is fairly critical.
Frame rates can be locked on both client and server
with the tick frequency changing accordingly.
However, we can also explicitly define our tick frequency
in the constructor of the class
should we want a very infrequent but consistent tick.
A tick can also be turned off and unregistered entirely
if your technical design doesn't require it.
End play is the actor's spin down function
and it's the opposite of begin play.
Typically this is used as a cleanup function.
Calling destroy on an actor marks it as pending kill
and begins the process of destroying the actor.
This involves calling begin destroy, finish destroy
and finally freeing up the memory.
Destroy is often called by engineers
and it's eventually rooted down into end play.
So we don't have to call that manually.
It's important to note that we can still access the actor
whilst it's in the process of being destroyed
but it will have the RF pending kill flag set on it.
We can see here that the actor life cycle
is actually fairly complex
and there's a number of different ways
we can initialize an actor.
We can see on the right hand side
that the actual spawning can be instant or deferred.
Deferred gives us a chance to change a value
on said actor before it hits begin play
and any subsequent gameplay functions that we've hooked in.
We can also see on the left that loading a map
also routes through the same begin play code
as our explicit spawning does,
whether it be from the direct loading of a map
or from clicking play in the editor.
We can also see that when and where
end play or destroy is called is also fairly fluid.
We can call destroy ourselves,
we can give an actor a lifetime
or we can simply exit the application.
Regardless, we need to make sure
that we're not leaving any actors unaccounted for.
They all route through end play functionality
marking them for kill and the eventual garbage collection.